super typhon éruption volcanique violent
tremblement de terre et canicules
interminable l'année 2015 était ponctuée
par des catastrophes naturelles
exceptionnelles
[Musique]
bilan de ces phénomène terrifiant vingt
mille victimes et presque 40 milliards
de dollars de dégâts
2015 s'affiche comme une année record
sur plusieurs points des tempêtes
tropicales d'une puissance inédite des
épisodes de sécheresse particulièrement
long et des températures les plus haute
mesurait depuis 130 ans faut-il y voir
les conséquences du réchauffement
climatique ou d'autres phénomènes plus
ponctuels comme el niño
le bilan de cette année 2015 est il
particulièrement édifiant en termes de
catastrophes naturelles
pas forcément en tout cas sur le plan
économique d'après robert wood qui
modélise les risques pour les compagnies
d'assurance on peut mesurer le coût
total planétaire des catastrophes
naturelles en estimant les pères c'est
probablement autour d'une centaine de
milliards d'euros toutes ensemble ou
dans cet ordre d'idées les catastrophes
naturelles ont bel et bien un impact
économique
ça c'est juste pour une année moyenne et
je ne sais pas encore pour cette année
mais je pense que nous serons en dessous
de cette moyenne dans des lieux comme
taïwan par exemple il y a beaucoup
d'assurance et il y a eu des pertes
cette année
s'il ya très peu d'assurance au népal
par exemple parce que c'est un pays
pauvre
donc globalement cette année a été très
calme en terme de risques d'assurance
même son de cloche du côté des
spécialistes des volcans à l'heure du
bilan malgré quelques épisodes
spectaculaires 2015 n'a pas défrayé la
chronique
c'était une année assez calme il y a eu
le calbuco et le barda bunga qui a
terminé son éruption
ça a donné un peu de temps aux
scientifiques pour analyser toutes les
données qu'ils avaient accumulé
c'est une très bonne année quand il ne
se passe pas grand chose
enfin pour les cyclones le bilan de
cette année 2015 est plus mitigé en
fonction des zones géographiques
au niveau mondial le nombre des cyclones
tropicaux est assez stable avec environ
80 système par an en revanche sur
l'atlantique l'année 2015 était
particulièrement calme
si on se réfère à l'ordre alphabétique
utilisé pour nommer les cyclones qui
apparaissent l'un après l'autre camp il
ya un niño donc avec des anomalies de
températures chaudes dans l'est du
pacifique en général l'activité
cyclonique sur l'atlantique est affaibli
à titre d'exemple l'année 2005 qui était
une année record
on a été jusqu'à z et puis une fois
arrivé à z on attaque les lettres de
l'alphabet alfa beta gamma delta et
sinon je crois qu'on est allé jusqu'à on
a eu trente et un phénomène dans l'année
2005 ce qui est un record absolu
puisqu'en moyenne en a
une dizaine dans l'atlantique de
phénomènes donc l'année 2005 à m voilà
c'est pour vous donner une fourchette
aujourd'hui on est à j ai en 2005 on a
attaqué les lettres de l'alphabet grec
malgré un grand nombre de catastrophes
naturelles 2015 n'a pas été aussi
dramatique qu'on pourrait le croire
[Musique]